President Biden taking one day out of
his second vacation this month to visit
fire ravaged Hawaii he is set to touch
down soon after facing intense criticism
for dismissing questions about his
administration's response during his
first getaway at the beach just two
weeks ago then the White House dodging
on details on how Biden is spending
those days off
I can't shed any light on how he's
spending some valuable quality family
time out here but certainly he's been
engaged on a daily basis and confronting
some of these extreme events procedure
the death toll in Maui rising to 114
people with over 850 still missing the
cause is still unknown while video
suggests downed power lines could have
started the fires that's not stopping
Hawaii's governor from insisting it was
climate change to blame
so just to be clear when you're talking
about global warming are you saying that
climate change Amplified the cost of
human error
yes it did there's no excuses to ever be
made but there are finite there are
finite resources sometimes in the moment
and now there's new scrutiny after an
official waited more than five hours to
release water during the fires that same
official giving this guidance last year
on how to distribute water equitably on
the island
let water connect us and not divide us
like we we can share it but it requires
true conversations about equity how do
we leave it better live coexist with the
resources that we have
That official has now been transferred
to another position and just one thing
if we could play the sound bite from the
Maui resident who's just upset about
where the president has been
it's really affected me because where's
the president aren't we Americans too
like we're part of the United States but
why are we not why are we getting put in
the back pocket why are we being ignored
to come to warm Memorial and see the
people there laying out and caughts
and see how he feels
Jesse Waters glad to have you here what
do you make of all of this Joe Biden's
the only person that spends more time on
vacation than I do and it took him five
days to address the deadliest wildfires
in modern American history took him six
days to address the Afghanistan
evacuation again he was on vacation for
both he had to be dragged Kicking and
Screaming to Maui he didn't want to go
out and talk to the Press about it
because the Press is going to act ask
him about Hunter Biden so he doesn't
even want an investigation into what
caused these fires and we know why is
because there was incompetence all over
this state
Sirens were not activated this guy wants
to share water with everybody except the
fire I'd share all the water with the
fire and then so they're asked this uh
Pharaoh farmer this indigenous Hawaiian
hey um do you mind if we share some of
this water with the fire department or
do you need it for your Pharaoh that I
think was a five hour lapse when they
could have gotten the water out there
this used to be an agricultural
Powerhouse Hawaii and then all of a
sudden it became a tourist trap and so
they let all of these non-native grass
species just go completely wild all over
the island completely mismanaged and now
the place is scorched the power company
doesn't spend a dime trying to clean up
the underbrush for all the foul Fallen
power lines to catch fire to and Biden
comes out and the media comes out and
they're going to blame global warming
Dana and talk about leading the witness
did you see the woman from CBS say what
you're saying is there's some dumb
people in Hawaii managing this but it's
probably the fault of Big Oil right
that's what we're doing here because you
can blame your incompetence on global
warming but global warming doesn't get
to respond to that and everybody now
just talks about global warming instead
of all the massive screw-ups that have
taken place on this poor island what
about a global warming pass Harold
so glad you're back the couple things
that when you have a catastrophe you
have a disaster like this and we we
remember when the shooting happened the
the young shooter in Uvalde and the
police showed up and we got a bunch of
conflicting stories and we finally
learned that it was incompetence gross
incompetence on the part of some and
even a lack of training I don't know
what they were doing there but you know
I think the focus on even in that issue
the guns was the wrong thing at the
outset you've got to rescue you've got
to recover you got to rebuild and
there's a part of it and as that goes on
you figure out the things you could be
doing very differently it could have
been done very differently there's
they're obviously serious serious uh
shortcomings and dysfunctions that
happen throughout this I would caution
everybody uh whatever agendas one may
have show some restraint let's figure
out number one can we have we recovered
everyone they're estimating they're
another thousand people uh that that may
be stranded still they may they may have
not recovered two let's figure out if
something were to happen tomorrow what
have we learned from this to ensure that
we don't have of the type of human era
that occurred this go around here and
finally as it relates to other things be
it climate change or whatever the issues
may be let's deal with that lasts we
still got a lot of Destruction
catastrophe in defense of the president
I thought it was wrong at times when
Democrats uh went after President Bush
when Democrats would go after president
Trump after even after the uh covet I
mean there are things presidents should
should or should not do I don't think
the President should have visited here
until now where I agree with those who
have been critical I was I was I was
surprised the president didn't show more
empathy at least in his public
statements about this but he will visit
he and the first lady will visit and
hopefully they won't take away from
resources that have been dedicated to
trying to find even those that are still
stranded judge I'll just mention this
and then of course comment on whatever
you want but the governor said that more
than 1800 people who lost their homes
they're having to live in hotel rooms
for the foreseeable future that could be
quite a long time yeah the truth is Dana
that uh when you look at the destruction
and the path of harm there's very little
that they can do to put this back
together in in a matter of even months I
mean they're for they've got to find
bodies they're going to do everything
they can to find whatever DNA they can
find but everything is charred I mean
we're talking about like a World Trade
Center here everything is charred it's
all a forensic analysis but you know it
is so disappointing and you could say
well the President should have been
there last week or this is the perfect
time all I can tell you is this the
president would not have been criticized
having shown any empathy when he was
asked while on vacation yet again in in
Delaware you know what do you think of
the rising number of the uh of the
deceased in uh in Maui in he goes no
comments I mean it's not like he didn't
hear it he is cold he doesn't care but
what's more significant is he said to
the people in Palestine Ohio I will go
to Palestine he promised to go there
that was seven months ago he never
showed up all right and finally let me
just say that you know the the
apparently the water could have been
used to help fight the fires but it
wasn't diverted from local streams into
the reservoirs which were dry at the
time of the fire that means that the
people in charge at the time were lazy
or incompetent just like Uvalde we
talked about people have got to get
their game up this guy I didn't turn the
sirens on because people would run up to
the Flames are you stupid no they're
going to run to the water stop with the
excuses
yeah I think you know if 9 11 happened
today the media would blame climate
change if Pearl Harbor happened they
would call it gun violence so that's the
world that we live in right now though
this to me is like the quietest tragedy
ever isn't it strange how quiet
everything is and in this case no news
is probably bad news you don't hear from
families of tourists because
maybe it's not tourists that are still
dead you know the Silence from the
locals because maybe they're gone and
then the officials don't say anything
because this is possibly worse than
anybody imagines you're not going to see
anybody and it's kind of scary who these
people might be right they might not be
adults and I think that this is a really
really horrible horrible tragedy and I
hope people learn that evil isn't some
guy with a twirly mustache you know
tying helpless women to train tracks
often it's a non-thinking unbending mind
that's adherent to an idea ideology if
this is true about this guy and the
five-hour delay of water he should never
walk this Earth safely again if he held
the water back while these people burned
alive and he thought well you need water
but you should appreciate the greater
goal of equity that's despicable I don't
believe it I can't believe somebody
would actually delay water for five
hours but then again we've seen the
ideology of equity show show up
everywhere you know we're told that it's
not about where you start it's where you
end up and everybody has to be the same
so while I understand that you might
need water uh to be safe there are other
people local farmers that deserve that
water too if that was actually the
conversation God help that person
because that's just disgusting I I again
we all become experts when these
tragedies happen but the one thing I'm
pretty clear on with ideology is that
they always put it before people and you
end up in situations like this where
they justify the death of others sad the
saddest part about this is we're there's
no noise it's just quiet and I'm
wondering why you know anyway okay so
the president's on the ground there now
so we'll keep you updated as that takes
place or about six five or six hours
behind us hi everyone I'm Brian Kilmeade
I want you to do me a favor I want you
to click to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page this is the only way that I
know for sure that you're not going to
miss any great commentary any great news
bites any great interviews coming your
way on Fox you can get it all here on
YouTube so subscribe right now